they write his name on his protective
suit but everybody knows who he is dr.
Phil Emma works at a remarkable clinic
where health workers treat victims of
Ebola but this doctor is extraordinary
he caught Ebola a virus that kills most
of its victims and survived it last
November we found him slumped in an
isolation tent wearing the stare of a
man contemplating death I tried to talk
to him but the medic said he was far too
weak on our final day in November a
nurse told us he had died to our
surprise we discovered that dr. Phil emo
had pulled through I'm feeling fine he
said and he invited us into his home we
came to see you before we were leaving
and you were not in the cube and a
health worker told us that you had died
in turbo mode
dr. Phil emo thinks he caught the virus
at the City of Benny's General Hospital
where he worked in the emergency room I
am Jamie Santa khamseh hello he demanded
Oprah levosa exam let me say due date is
a noble scientific available yeah you
know no the LA for Soulja Mesa Sedona
bola it must have been incredibly
frightening Louis Sofia don't be sayin
clean of Vienna more when he was sick
his wife and his daughters came to visit
him every day but dr. Phil mo was so ill
he didn't recognize them for the first
five days but life has returned to
normal more or less and we found his
children in the outside
Esther will you be a doctor when you
grow up quiet
that's good she almost is like a Swami
illusion as an Ebola survivor the doctor
is now immune from infection and he's
been deployed to the cities treatment
center but the hours are brutal for
Benny is at the heart of the epidemic
suction I work every day he says he
begins his shift and finds a patient
called kuvira who's in a desperate state
she's unresponsive he calls for a drip
and oxygen then a resuscitate the
woman's husband and son wait nearby
[Music]
it takes three hours to stabilize the
patient and we find him drenched in
sweat in the decontamination zone why do
you work here well when you almost lost
your life yo DJ producer mark we Jellico
pass on the malady [ __ ] arriba so VD
we don't say a mama say mama th amsa dr.
Phil Amano's in a way few others could
he knows what his patients are going
through and he'll do anything he can to
keep them alive John sparks Sky News and
Benny